[Music]
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast live we have been gone
for a minute were bad we weren't gone
today - bless you function y'all know
you sees all the time as never said it
what you got yeah it was I'm sick like
my god
if only I could get some sympathy that
would be a really lovely New York it is
Tuesday we have been we've been working
we haven't been gone we've been right
here but just nobody I didn't live which
is bicoastal we're some bicoastal
podcasters we spent all week in LA and
the west coast just turning our content
if you haven't checked out our la Week
episodes they're all up on YouTube and
on our iTunes we had guests Morgan
Stewart Brad Goreski Gary Jannetty Tonya
rad Becca Tilly tisha Adams and finally
yesterday's episode we concluded la week
with Lauren Elizabeth went with an
amazing announcement that Lauren is
launching a podcast on our network toast
news network it was he and it is called
mood everything with Lauren Elizabeth
you could check it out it's available
now on Spotify and iTunes feel free to
subscribe great review of the whole
thing episodes are coming out every
Wednesday so tomorrow her first episode
launches and feel free to support a
chestnut network news talent yeah it's
really exciting
I'm personally I'm excited to listen to
it me too some tips and tricks on how to
be an issue such an interesting girl yes
she is but she also has like tips and
tricks just for living yeah like I've
learned a lot of things through her
Instagram and I look forward to continue
the learning process yeah everyone think
about Ellie we counter snitch what do
you think about la are you still snitch
Chamberlin now that we're back know I'm
very much back yeah back to my root
you're ugly Chamberlin yes
I'm I felt good about it I was I was
happy for like the first four days and
then the rest was just pure misery oh it
was just the time that you spent alone
with me mm-hmm
oh well it was toast LA it was like
really fun but like it was like a lot of
reward
for a lot of like effort you know even
like I felt like we weren't getting out
what we were putting in but we are
putting in so much so we did a lady gang
episode which I believe is out today if
you want to check it out it was really
fun
unfortunately Becca Tobin wasn't there
so I couldn't ask her more questions
about Lady but Jackman neck was there
and we met her and we kind of you know
we we there dodged it yeah even though
that wasn't hot yet no but like we did
say some stuff and we had to answer for
our sins and we did and I think she was
like totally cool well and now she's
gonna come on this show she's like cool
too like Aryan when she's in town in
November she's gonna come on the toes so
that kept you there so check it out and
then what else did we do we didn't it
files podcast one coming out may be
coming out I guess it would have come
out this morning I don't know it's still
early holidays like two weeks but that
was like a week ago so I mean the shows
come out on Tuesday so is either today
or next Tuesday ok state look out for it
I didn't have the McDonald's podcast
which was really fun and has already
come out it was just like lots of good
stuff you know lots of lots of talking I
feel as though by the end of the week I
officially ran out of things to talk
about which is saying a lot for me I
know but it made me realize like maybe
if we're not meant to be morning show
host thing maybe were meant to be
afternoon show host because we had so
much more energy but what we always
thought the town was it the town because
you were there and you're a getting like
you were giving it you guys know we
don't have energy right now but we're
giving it our all like we always give it
our all just because we have to it's
literally it's what pays our rent I know
but like we tried so hard in LA and like
we said like if we tried have like if we
try too hard we try hard here but like
we've had spray tans we were snatched we
were a new clothes like really just
caring about everything like I would be
broke if I had to live every day like my
LA I change so much money on clothing
I had a [ __ ] revolve order sent to
the hotel we're at a control we're out
of control like with my getting my hair
done like I I can't I can't literally
can't afford to look like that every day
it's a special time also it's pointless
because even if we got all like glammed
up and you go to take pictures in New
York City you look like a big duty ball
yeah I feel like LA just makes you look
like an angel because it's the true
danger and it's the warm Sun and the
light like it's a really good for
citizen tria ly matter what we look like
in New York because there's just a great
cloud over everything I tell you
something about my show in San Francisco
sure you know who I met too stylish
teens oh the girl she was talking to me
and we were just like having a
conversation and she was like this cute
girl right it's cute opening ceremony
dress and then she that waited till the
very end to drop the bomb that she was
tired
jeans and I'm like what I mean I was
like you're literally our favorite
intern we have just like I know I need
to be more active I'm like yes she was
posting last night yes so and I told her
I'm like can you try and post like all I
wear super cheap clothes like virtually
disposable but then like expensive
handbags like oh they pose the expense
of handbags everyone thinks gonna think
I'm a billionaire like you know like
literally everything I'm wearing is from
Amazon you know them to know this from
forever 21
these pants are from top of these shoes
are from we mean fur delicious my fur
need to start tipping her off cuz I feel
like she only knows your expensive
hammocks it says it's Louie Vuitton but
I shouldn't know what your t-shirt is so
I was just like really excited to meet
her like I don't know and she just like
dropped the bomb on me I was like oh my
god Silas jeans that's pretty cool
she was and you know what she's a great
representative for our bread she was
like this q but she's stylish seen very
stylish weird like an opening ceremony
like Geoffrey ze
very steamy and very stylish Wow I love
to hear it
yes me Margot you know we had a we had a
long weekend we hit up San Diego two
shows in San Francisco I haven't done
two shows in one night that's how I
started look when I was in comedy clubs
you get the room for the night so you
want to make as much money but like it's
so physically laborious doing
meet-and-greets show show meet-and-greet
like we were there two o'clock meeting
at home till midnight
and I stopped doing that because now I'm
playing like bigger venues so I don't
need to do two shows I'm just doing
lunch yeah but in San Francisco we
launched a second show and like it was
the longest day of our lives like we
were in the green room like not okay
ordering cpk like watching Glee like I
need a full-body rubdown I just wanted
you like a wellness check on the
snatchler she's not okay because last
time we saw her on the show she had a
sty and it was just like a bad day yeah
and how are you doing now like did you
have an allergic reaction oh yeah oh my
god I'm the plane yes I'm not allergic
to anything or so I thought up until
this point in my life I haven't been and
I had the warm nuts and then all of a
sudden my like throat was starting to
close I'm not the upper this part of my
lip felt like really numb to the touch
and like hold it was just a sensation I
had never felt before which is why I
think I drove to the reaction of it
being an allergic reaction because like
what else could it be
it was really freaky yes it wasn't just
like your body rejecting like working
overtime probably I feel like if that
was it like I just like wouldn't have
felt like you know this you have to
listen to your body that's the lesson
whenever - and honestly I was like
really freaked out it's like when it
comes to algae sometimes when people are
overdramatic but then like next thing
you know they're dead no one else when
it comes
to anything happening on a plane yeah so
we asked the flight attendant for a
benadryl but like because of these
litigious times no one would give us
anything
and then we convinced one flight
attendant to give us a benadryl and
Marco fell asleep and was totally fine
yeah it's like scary for like a couple
minutes cuz you always hear about those
people who like die so it was like I was
either dying or it was gonna be an
emergency landing and then like everyone
would hate you actually that would have
been worse because no one would hate you
more than Claudia right now and then
like you'd be dead and like I would be
to blame them like and my sisters and I
made the plane land and now I'm in
Detroit right right yeah it was touch
and go for a minute but but we were
fighting out alive do you guys want to
know a crazy fact to me about me no
because I don't want to hear about your
wonderful weekend because that's like 26
an hour it's better than that what's so
much better than that what I saw
obviously I'm here today dressed and
ready this is the first time I'm leaving
my house since I got home from the air
so Friday are you so jealous
I saw air daylight son Oh Cody do you
want to talk about the porn oh my god I
cannot even tell you my experience at
Alaska Airlines and I feel as if it's an
unfair represented a representation of
Alaska Airlines me Margo flew from San
Diego to San Francisco but you think you
could drive but you definitely can't now
you could take the train like in Real
Housewives of art that was to LA like
yeah the Pacific Coast liner I heard I
tried to look as nice yeah it did sound
nice but is too much work for us to do
it so I'd never flew in Alaska Airlines
before I got on the plane and I was
shipped because it was like literally
the biggest nicest plane ever like I
could've done a cartwheel like there's
so much space it was so confusing I
never experienced anything like it
me marker sitting in the second row and
in the first row is this couple who were
just like giving me weird vibes to start
and like the second they sit down like
they could not stop touching each other
and the thing is with these airlines
with this specific airline was that the
first-class seats like you were sitting
in a and B so you were next to each
other but there was such a big gap
between the two chairs that sitting
behind someone it's like I was watching
a movie like I got a whole screen into
these people's lives and the more you
think about it the more I realize these
people were probably having an affair
because like they just couldn't get
enough it's like they were going back
home to their families and like they
just wanted to [ __ ] one last time
so me and Margo had the extremest
fortune they were on their way to the
affair
they were excited yeah and they were
excited yeah it's like you affair in San
Francisco or San Diego like San Diego
home or San Francisco home oh it could
be either obviously they're like the
same thing but you know what was weird
they they were like the the social
events coordinator of the flight like
they knew everyone on the plane like
people are getting in from the bathroom
so then it couldn't get funnier and the
tattoo the girl so we couldn't have been
a fair thing new people they were having
an affair in broad daylight you know
what this guy was [ __ ] disgusting
yeah notice it yeah second he sat down
people so we're sitting and people are
still boarding and this girl comes on
she's like a cool girl she's got
backpack she wearing a short-sleeved
shirt she's like a huge tattoo sleeve on
her arm and this guy he's like asking
her questions about her tattoo while
like touching and gracing her arm which
is like and now we know where of hands
his hands but like even if his hands
weren't up another woman's vagina like
if anyone ever touched my arm like I
would be so don't [ __ ] touch man lady
was like lifting her sleeve but yeah he
was she wasn't like showing him the
tattoo like he was literally taking it
for himself
so we knew he was weird and then we
proceeded to sit behind him for 90
minutes while he literally finger to
scroll friend I made out with her choked
her choked him pulled her hair and
literally I have so many videos of it on
my phone because I couldn't believe and
I knew no one would believe me like if I
to get a video I knew nobody would
believe me that I saw literally he put
his singers up his girl's vagina and I
was gonna put him on Instagram but like
remember when that girl did that whole
Twitter threat about that you have
falling in love and then she got like
hey she got so much trouble for just
like writing a love story I'm like that
was a positive thing so I just like
tried to take that as a lesson being
like if I post these people like I'll
get in trouble or whatever so I posted
one video where I kind of blacked out
their face where they literally are just
like sucking each other's noses it was
so disgusting that video suffice is
because I I know you guys are asking I
did see the videos yeah there's a couple
people to get me like who I know and
they're like let me see I'm like okay
that's all my friends they were pretty
horrifying honestly but the one that you
posted like sums up the gross miss yes
out being like we're not seeing vagina
explained you don't see vagina in the
videos but like you get the gist of the
nastiest you don't need to see if the
trying to know where the hands maginot
live you don't need to see any more than
what you posted to understand that these
people were discussing it was so crazy
um I like sucking your nose like I could
die and like I
you know it's like someone could have
been someone could say that why didn't
you just like stop looking it's like I
was trying to watch the fabulous world
of jeffree star but literally my eyes
kept getting pulled like I just I
couldn't not look it was literally like
a train wreck
I was rubbernecking okay she really I
was I was in the seat on the window and
I was able to somewhat block the view
cloudy head I was right there like they
were basically jumping in my lap it was
so insane like violas feeling queasy
like I think we actually need to move on
look I know this is mean to say but if
they were like cute like I wouldn't been
so terrible but they could have been
cute and what no one kissing like that
is appetizing for yeah so they were like
cute people and then they start like
playing tongue swords and then I don't
even want to tell you then yeah nope
what's yeah weird nobody's hand in the
snack basket oh yeah he put his hand in
the snack basket there was some
unwrapped fruit in there really not cool
nobody else could eat anything me am I
gonna took wrapped cheez-its and I was
still very very trepidatious and then
when we got off the plane they stood up
and walked and like we walked right
behind them and there was just weird
things in the seat you know like where
they both have been sitting okay now I'm
gonna use this to segue to the fact that
we both watch to Jeffrey Stehr Shane
Dawson documentaries Sophia the last
episode in watch the last 20 minutes
because I was busy like watching porn
okay well we are gonna recap it and
whatever happened last 20 minutes
hopefully like I won't spoil for you but
I think you get the gist you know I have
been like really getting on Jackie and
Margo to watch it because I have like
recently fall in love with Geoffrey star
and like I know it's super controversial
and I went back and watched a lot of the
old videos in the first series with
Jeffrey's with Shane Dawson where he
talks about like why he got canceled
it's actually super interesting so oh I
might have to watch that I actually I
didn't know how I felt about every
surfer so long because it's like he
doesn't like Kylie which makes me not
like me too but I like his like
brazenness and and his business and it's
all really impressive and like his
branding and I need his [ __ ] closet
like is no specific like what dreams are
made of but I just the jury was how for
me and now the jury is is back in it was
you know everyone voted unanimously that
we love and we stare and I just have the
most respect for him respect and I
literally went and I bought Margaret $60
jawbreaker palette because I wanted an
eyeshadow
but I don't really wear eyeshadow but
Margot does well I went as well as six I
wanted to buy something cuz when he was
talking about his eyeshadows being like
the best quality like I was like oh
that's what I need um
but none of them like we're we're it's
not it's not for us like who just wear
like neutrals it's for people who like
to create like full looks and make
youtube videos about it like okay Margot
so I got her a palette she was just like
one neutral palette for like all the
basic girls who are now being introduced
to you know same and just call it like
the Geoffrey start basic palette because
no I I went on because and I bought a
couple of liquid lipsticks because I've
also heard they're very good but I
couldn't get a palette because I don't
really [ __ ] with eyeshadow okay we'll
get into that later I think now it is
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and
it's time for sure for sure for sure I
don't want to get too ahead of myself
you know by getting into the stories
before letting everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you but
one of our favorite long-standing brands
here at the morning toast set bird our
week in LA was sponsored by Sandberg oh
yeah because you know I did not fall in
shower and actually at the meeting
greets this weekend met a lot of girls
I'm like you guys smell so good and they
were all wearing said bird it's
incredible like it's just a necessity
and according to said bird scent is the
most powerful sense you have a smell can
bring on a flood of memories very true
influence your mood and of course
enhance your natural style so you always
want to be that girl who smells good you
know what you did I have a couple
friends with like you know like scents
that are so damn and I'm like jealous
cuz like I don't have like a distinct
smell you know that's because you're a
scent bird right and I'm always just
like flock yeah [ __ ] love that probably
like I love seeing cloudy you never know
what she's gonna smell it right she's
just like a potpourri of excitement what
perfumes so assembler is a luxury
fragrance subscription service for
perfumes and colognes they have more
than 600 designer brands for you to
choose from
every month you choose the perfume you
want to try they'll send you a 30-day
supply if you're not sure what type of
scent you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance my brand
style occasion season and more plus they
have products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup they're
carry brands like Kapow a personal
favorite here at the morning toast glam
glow glow recipe tart and so many more
so basically the whole premise is
they'll send you it they look like small
bottles but they actually like over 100
sprays in them which is more than enough
for a month's supply and you get to use
it for the month
coming like these the best part is
tempered is the carrying cases they come
in a little Swiss table yeah and they'd
be super cute colors and then you can
get a new fragrance every month you can
try out different once they have
fancy-ass
perfume bottles that like if you bought
in a store would be been sent hundreds
so with our exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 30% off your first
month today that's only $10 for your
first fragrance go to scent bird dot-com
slash toast or use our code toast for
30% off your first month again that's
sent bird SC ent the IRD dot-com slash
toast for you to try your first perfume
or cologne at just $10 sign on smell
amazing oh you guys what a good one what
a good one honestly I love Sandberg
reviews I love some reads is that like
it's know also like reviews like getting
feedback from people who bought tempered
for sure but I love a day when it's a
Sanford Reno me too that's just like oh
we're chillin was tempered we're signing
on we're smelling the mean right way
what's good cow and that's do for me
smelling amazing you know right be rare
this like so many of our sponsors have
really transformed their lives and now
we're smelling amazing okay first story
a little happy been news Shay Mitchell
gave birth but not without posting a
YouTube video showing her enduring 33
hours of labor in an emotional burst you
notice thinking about when I heard this
story I was think about all the pretty
little liars girls like what they did
after pretty little pretty little liars
I don't have to I think which a Mitchell
did and has done is probably the most
impressive of all the gals because she
was Inc trying going to the Royal
Wedding it's not impressed that's pretty
impressive but like but that shake like
that's great her husband I know Shay
Mitchell was like out here thirsting on
YouTube like at her at the height of her
popularity which I'm sure was like not
was like was like a thirsty move for her
it was that she saw the writing on the
wall she's a genius because it's like
stuff like that doesn't last forever
like you could be on the number one show
and then like nobody cares about you and
that's it something would happen to a
lot of the girls and I think what she
did is genius and I think like literally
YouTube is making her millions of
dollars and I just think it's genius and
then she also has her travel company oh
base yeah I have a few items it's pretty
good yeah so I wonder how that does her
well there was a Forbes article that is
it amazing oh yeah okay label I did see
that
well it didn't have specifics in it like
this I don't know if this year was great
but it's great I just reread line like
Jeffries
are great no no no but great couldn't
eat anything yeah and also I feel like
no one talks about numbers and if I had
to have guesstimated Jeffery stars
numbers like the amount of units that
he's ordering is so much more than I
would have ever thought when he'd flip
back that calculator around talking
about what he takes home from a pallet
mm-hmm I was like it's probably gonna be
like max like and I was thinking I was
so crazy like five or six million twenty
eight million
I was shook well do you want to hear
something even crazier because Jeffrey
star isn't a billionaire but Kylie
Jenner is which means that Kylie
cosmetics pallets take home more and
she's making more units which is insane
yeah but also what Jeffrey explains that
her cost of goods is probably way lower
perhaps yeah yeah I mean I it's easy for
him to say like that might be it is easy
for him to say that but it does look and
by the way I don't think he was oh he
did talk about Kylie cosmetics nevermind
I think he didn't and he was more so
shading like the time to shade like
fellow beauty brands by like by
influencers I know it was real like the
like the two phases of the and you know
what they need to be shamed because I
what they do is [ __ ] criminals
Sephora is abbath contrived agree and I
kind of love that Jeffrey star won't
sell in Sephora not even Ulta no I mean
I wish she would sell in Ulta and I'd
like Alto because like they haven't
makes appreciate but like Sephora yeah
and he could never like they stand for
everything he like preaches and works
against yeah corporate greed corporate
if I can greed it's insane in the makeup
industry hasn't learning anyways back to
Shay Mitchell she give the name no no
but she took to Instagram on Sunday to
announce the birth of her first born
with partner partner partner Matt babble
in the first photo she shared her baby
girl she wrote never letting go I cannot
believe she was in labor for 33 hours
like you said normal I I don't think
it's not normal but not every labor is
33 hours I feel like I definitely got
that log in yeah that is on the long end
that's so quick you captured the whole
thing for her YouTube video because she
is dedicated to that premium cotton you
know and she's been Khurana lying the
whole journey but yeah on her YouTube
channel which is which is cool I didn't
watch the birthing video I don't think
she's gonna like show like the actual
birth I just like those things freaked
me out yeah I don't want to watch it but
I got you know it takes me so long to
get into like someone's YouTube channel
no it's taken and like
even with the Jeffrey Stehr I know we
keep bringing it back to Jeffrey star
but it's like even with the evolution
like I just like used to watch his
reviews because I thought it was funny
he would go to like TJ Maxx in like only
by TJ Maxx makeup and like really like
rip on it
and then I just heard just like like him
and then I like likes his dogs and yeah
it's really just words you know I don't
think this is gonna happen for me but I
I'm not the target demo no I just I
really want to commend and put it out
there like what Jay Mitchell did with
her with her fame like it could have
been 15 minutes like which it was for
like something that girls like or some
of them are just still actresses trying
to act and whatever it's good that like
Shane Mitchell's
she's a revolve girl she's an actress
she's maybe she yeah and she's also
evolving with the times
yeah it's I think that's very impressive
and I remember when she was doing it I'm
like why is this like huge superstar
like pushing her YouTube you know
madellaine is doing its but yes is what
madam should keep doing it yes smart
move forever delicate it's a smart move
for someone who gets on a show that like
is very hot but it's not gonna stay hot
forever like it's not it's nobody ever
throw it's not a guarantee never even
Game of Thrones like those people are
out of work yeah but like Game of
Thrones was like they went out on top
yeah they went out still the
most-watched show on television but like
that's not gonna pay the bills you know
but it definitely will make it easier
for them to get roles like I think by
the time they're super like nice they
are you know and a lot of the time
Pretty Little Liars was over it was like
alright no if anything like then it's
it's a wonderful springboard like they
were on a teen show now they can be
adults and do movies like everyone's
really in the same spot and like Game of
Thrones it's like you're some like
medieval no but they're very method but
can you ever seen what they look like in
real life yeah but like they see how
much into the character they got but
it's I don't know I I haven't seen like
a game of Thrones stars like moved on to
zoom but I'm familiar Christmas movie oh
yeah she like loves to throw herself
into a rom-com every now and what she
does and so does Nikolai's the other yes
he's like randomly in like the most
other woman yeah and I guess I mean he
was in fighting with my family I've
never heard of oh yeah oh we I never
watched it but I've heard of it it was
decent
who else like sophie Turner what's next
for her well she's like part four right
true true you know what I'm feeling my
argument and now even more because and
then you know it's a get those Pretty
Little Liars
they could have gone on you know Plato's
but no I mean Lucy house still acts
Ashley Benson I think she's trying
Benson is in another stratosphere now
which of what a theme what Cara
Delevingne Ashley Benson like oh that's
not to me she's more relevant than ever
oh yeah Cara Delevingne has saved her
really and that's exactly what she did
no I see so relevant she's at the
airport like that never would have went
on before Cara yeah people in the camera
they could all get together are so
interesting oh I think it's like it
should be so interesting in Cara's still
interesting but it's like it's just oh
my god no I'm so here for them I heard
they got married like less me good but
look right and I didn't hear that
because nobody cares no everyone cares I
think they're so interesting I think I
love them look like I care so much about
that I think she's falling off something
I hear nothing about her and I think
that's how she wants it like I don't
think she wants no I think she wants to
be all like off the face of the earth
but now her new relationship is like
making people more intrigued oh my god I
feel not that way at all I never hear
about them like I'm gonna they're always
on the tail email like I hear about them
all the time and I think they're so
interesting I'm so happy for them I hope
they did get married yeah I'm happy for
them like they're like me everyone's
happy that likes I so don't care about
Ashley Benson oh no I do I'm very I like
them a lot I think they're cool yeah and
you know he's doing really well for
herself Mona you know Paris yeah she's
don't tell the boys she don't stop
working she don't stop working she can't
stop getting work so yeah it's it could
be who's the other one Oh Sasha bull
shoes on the new oh my god that's not
gonna work
ladies and gentlemen oh my god I think
we should bring the cameras s-someone oh
my god totally like Punk'd yeah that was
so crazy that was someone we should put
like a trigger warning oh sorry guys hey
some construction going on upstairs and
realize they're filming like the biggest
live show ever downstairs
Wow nobody sorry that was jarring like I
need a minute anyways we can go back to
arguing about this another time
yeah because let's move on to our second
story Jennifer Lawrence is a married
woman
very exciting she got married in Rhode
Island this weekend to cook a pig Moroni
in front of 150 guests including Ashley
Olsen Adele Amy Schumer and Kris Jenner
at the luxurious Belcourt of Newport a
mansion in Newport Rhode Island that was
designed in 1894 by renowned American
architect Richard Mars hunt I feel like
we definitely went there on a field trip
yeah like when you were visiting the
estates of the Rockefellers yeah and now
it's currently owned by the CEO of Alex
and Ani Wow who knew Iran did sell oh
yeah wait okay so that was the most
interesting part of the whole thing was
when I was reading about it said the
venue was owned by Allison on a CEO and
I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
those ugly bracelets but in the state
okay but those ugly bracelets are
everywhere and for a long time they were
like the you know they were the rite of
passage for like sixteen-year-old girls
like it was everyone's sweet 16 present
like they were just ubiquitous and now
like they have all these advertisements
I really think they're raking it in but
it's like their second act the follow-up
to the bracelets hasn't very strong but
there still have a ton of money yeah a
ton of money and it was like a
successful brand made off the backs of
heinous bracelet it's like no one ever
could refer like consider those
bracelets speak you well I feel as
though the snatcher would know because
it's really a bit for her jaw now
tsunami now it's not a bracelet no ugly
did you ever wear one did you ever wear
one no of her own one no about your
friends nope
Jones you feel like it was the
equivalent of like the tiffany charm
bracelet like whatever we got for their
buffets huh and look at Tiffany's
yeah but like I paid to the city even I
wouldn't wear right now like a Tiffany
charm bracelet is still cute like you
know it sounds like we're showing
someone the way in our attic yeah but I
don't think they can hear that and
they're getting restless I don't think
they can hear that I think we can just
hear them yeah they're working on it no
but that's what it sounds like even now
looking in hindsight I think that a
Tiffany charm bracelet is pretty cute
and I wouldn't necessarily like cringe
of it the way I cringe
tsunami bracelet well it's cute in an
ironic way and just give a tsunami
sometime no but I just I feel very
strongly about the fact like I remember
seeing it blow up they were on every on
top of every taxi like they'd so much
money for advertising dollars and if you
really strongly like to put it out there
like the brand was was made successful
by ugly bracelets like it's it's
important that we not forget that yeah
it is an ugly brand and I'm sorry like I
know that's me to say but it is okay
well I'm glad she did well for herself
well enough to not only like have a
house where Jennifer Lawrence would
marry but I'm sure like she got the
invite you know really yeah she's rented
out a house yeah like when you are so
rich I give these huge estates like
people can have a certain stature can
like rent it it has nothing to do I
don't emili´s unless you enter Lawrence
knows her I don't think that she got
invited at all I think Jennifer Lawrence
has to know her why would she choose
this random woman's out in rote housing
or a tile well it might be like like an
estate it sound like a random woman's
house like a cottage like it's like it's
it's a known venue you know because it's
so big or something like my friend when
I went to wedding in Mexico like they
rented this estate and like they didn't
know the guy but it's just like a
beautiful place okay I feel like they
know each other but I'm just a baby
couldn't either totally could they
totally could if they didn't know if she
didn't know her she definitely never buy
that look she just read of course of
course after the wedding guests party
late into the night and snacked on past
burgers and other offerings from
Boston's baddest food truck and mainly
Lobster at the Bel Court and that's
that's how it's fellow mobster St EAH
you wrote this so people magnets in the
name of the place my god Margo pay
attention of the lessor sorry it's ours
is the name of the lobster place lobster
god that's cute it's like a Rhode Island
you know like I don't know how to Austin
New England by the time the after party
sorry around 12:30 a.m. hungry stars
headed out for a snack honestly like I
feel as though Jennifer Lawrence's crew
like that is something that gives me
FOMO where it's like she has like fine
taste she's a fun girl and like Kris
Jenner Amy Schumer and Adele like those
are the people I want ever shown and mr.
Miller look so fun so we're fine but
people who definitely know how to throw
down when the time comes
hundred percent you definitely want Kris
Jenner out you're running and I can't
believe Kris Jenner came like I feel
like we've seen the evolution of their
friendship just for like Jennifer
Lawrence being an enormous fan of the
Kardashians hosting the Jimmy Kimmel
show and then like using it as an
opportunity
to talk to the Kardashians which is
exactly what I would do and like I feel
like we saw her on that episode member
they got drunk and then Chris came on
yeah like I now feel like we've watched
evolution of their friendship to the
point where it's like now kris Jenner's
invited Jennifer Lawrence's wedding
that's cool that's really really cute
yeah big fan I like their friendship I
just like Jen we get closer with some of
the girls my diary Jen and Chloe closer
I feel like they would have a glass
that's actually a good call I feel like
maybe the girls were resilient cuz like
she did come off like a little
surprisingly like thirsty
you know resilient hesitant oh sorry
yeah I guess they're very strong no like
they're not into the idea of like
basically like them thirst like heard
like thirsting for the friendship also I
think at this point it's like their
mom's friend Jen yeah also like they
don't need the friendship at some point
like you could have said like they need
a movie star friend like they don't need
it now you know yeah they've got plenty
of movie star friends dinner I don't
know you guys need to pretend like it's
on you but like you guys there's just we
have a stowaway
no yeah they what's it called a squatter
we have a squatter like by the way ever
since I like I'm convinced there's a
squatter in my apartment and once I
didn't answer I'm sorry like thinking
that there was people giving me like the
craziest story I mean I once saw the
craziest oh I know which I'm you're
talking I told me that one time they had
someone living behind their that mirror
vanity like you know in a bathroom like
you look up I wanna comment I mean now I
always seems like if I pulled in there
out of the wall like would there be a
person like a real human or like a ghost
it was person a squatters a person well
but how do they feed behind a wall right
that's the thing it's like they could
live anywhere oh my god I'm smaller you
creaking yeah I'd like you know that
they've been there because they're like
shoes are there there's like snack
wrappers like it's the whole squatter
what are they getting it out so crazy
look through the vents and stuff it's
just this shaky I don't think that
happens in apartments agreed I think it
does I think it's more so in homes
marquees please just go with that yeah
but I thought you know I challenge you
to do a quick Google search it'll shock
you I'm gonna pass I'm gonna passed you
anyways Joe Giudice speaks out for the
first time since leaving for Italy okay
we've got more information on
the Giudice clan most notably the fact
that they are doing a sit-down with Andi
on - I was so skinny oh I mean it's
crazy he didn't even call him juicy Joe
anymore no he's no longer a juicy he's
like he's just Joe he's Hollow Joe just
Joe just Joe it's really so crazy and I
wonder what's next for this family I
mean we're gonna find out on Sunday when
Italy sits down with them how maybe
they're going to Italy to film it
or like he's teleconferencing in or I
hope not it's a teleconference like I'm
out honestly I think they're definitely
gonna Italy I think why not like a
little kiss the girls like to see him -
yeah yeah and they're gonna like they're
gonna visit him in stuff so why not just
like take a trip make some money and
they don't wait for it
right no but also they're definitely
gonna make a lot of money because yeah
this is it this is a moment we've been
waiting for like all of this started
what six years ago like we are finally
on the other side of it like we need to
go back and discuss everything do you
remember when her and Joe went on while
shopping five before yes their lawyers
like telling them to plead guilty but
they got paid to do that right
definitely so I wonder how much this is
probably even more how much they're
getting paid I feel like a million
dollars but see - and I feel like
they're not above that's like an amount
they would take you know yeah for sure I
think they're still paying restitution
let me need the the finances Bravo Bravo
was literally paying restitution on
behalf of the Giudices for sure but
Bravo's also probably the one that shine
a light on their troubles 1,000 so it
all comes out in the wash down Oh Andy
Cohen started his second book he said
that he went on the view and I don't
want to misquote but I think it was
Whoopi Goldberg or one of the ladies
they were reporting on Teresa's
sentencing and when the cameras went
down they were like you did this yeah
like you made a monster and this is all
I'm Bravo well it seems like they were
living above their means before the show
started yeah he didn't create that
monster but no but this shield every
escalate it escalated it and then also
like brought it to me like I don't know
that the government would have cared so
much about these people and taking them
down and making an example out of them
if they didn't become public figures and
if all of their wealth wasn't flown on
the show they couldn't lie about certain
things like they couldn't say they
weren't like building this house or
spending this money that they didn't
have but like it's all on TV
proof yeah yeah so I think it just it
wasn't good um I'm actually do see the
trailer for the New Jersey season I
guess it's New Jersey season yeah they
talk a lot about Tracy's boyfriend which
like that's been like an unspoken thing
it's like her and Joe have really not
been together for quite a while I'm like
she's been dating I mean like there's
pictures of it on the Daily Mail
snapchat but like nobody seems to care
but it seems like it becomes a storyline
and this season which I'm actually
really looking forward to because tweets
a deserves a man like yeah this is some
[ __ ] this is I mean if I were Teresa
like I would never could never like she
went to [ __ ] jail for this guy it
wasn't even like that great to her to
begin with and he wasn't even sorry like
that's the craziest party and she missed
out on that last year with her mom which
I think like that really of all the
things like she could look past that was
the one thing she couldn't look past
it's like did her mom died while she was
in prison I know I think it was right
after but she had just missed out 15
months yeah
so that was like the one thing like you
can walk all over me you can yell at me
but like you took away the last year of
being my mom and like that I don't my
prefer you before and I feel like that
was really the straw that broke Teresa's
back yeah it's just crazy times like
okay great for our next story that said
that Joey skyping in so no free trip to
Italy oh the comments are alleging that
he is which doesn't have the same power
I'm sorry
I need them sitting together like fake
holding hands you know yeah I need to
see their body language
anyone can like fake it over Skype right
right and like what about what if the
connections bad and also it's kind of
weird that like they haven't seen him
yet it's not like they can't afford a
trip to Italy like they did they're
always traveling like dude I just got
out of jail like what are you gonna say
maybe he wants to like get set up in
Italy so they're not like coming and
it's you you know he he's a lot of kids
only there no but like he needs it like
in an apartment and like somewhere to
bring the kids where are the kids gonna
sleep like it's just if they come and
he's like so unsettled I think it would
like it would shake them even more maybe
yeah you know but still it's like that
you want to see your job yeah I don't
know it's not so easy yeah yeah and like
they're in school they're in school
anyways um next story a little crazy
business
oh my god this story's so crazy a little
what crazy business
skincare startup Sunday Riley told to
stop leaving fake reviews on Sephora
website a skincare startup Sunday Riley
was ordered by the FTC Monday to stop
leaving fake reviews on their products
of Sephora's webpage in an effort to
boost sales a report said in agreement
with the FTC Texas based skincare
company Sunday Riley agreed to not leave
fake reviews on Sephora's website in the
future but the company did not have to
admit it did so in the past BuzzFeed
news reported so this all started
someone a former employee posted to
Reddit a screenshot of an email where
higher-ups at Sunday Riley encouraged
well no not encouraged tell the
employees to leave reviews on sephora's
website they show them how how to use a
VPN to hide their IP address like litter
know the lengths that they should go to
and like just like it was de rigueur if
anyone has any questions feel free to
contact sunday or some of the other
leaders and like on her new that is her
name is sunday riley is it mm-hmm that's
great news but this is so bad for her
Google search yeah so it was like just
all spelled out for you and how to like
hide your IP just cuz they knew that
they were doing something great so then
the reddit community just like went up
an arms BuzzFeed like launched an
investigation just copying the BuzzFeed
the reddit thread article like
journalists these days love to do that
like they find an interesting thread on
like reddit or Gomi and then they write
it up a verbatim like plagiarize it and
then take credit for it yeah but I guess
like someone needs to write it up in
order for the FTC to care about it um
and you have to see now cares and they
just have told go me too I mean Riley to
stop doing it they didn't have to admit
that they get it even though it's like
clear as day that yeah and it's just
like a crazy [ __ ] factoid so I heard
about this because the FTC like released
their statement in a they posted it a
bunch of places in addition to Twitter
and they tweeted like a bunch of things
in a thread and jeffree star replied to
it being like this is the type of
transparency we need in the beauty
industry and a there's even also alleged
that they might have like purchase
Instagram Twitter Facebook followers and
engagement like faking like comments and
likes Oh like since they started for
sure I mean this stuff this doesn't seem
like step 1 like getting a VPN hiding
right
address and responding to support
comments where someone since this
product was like they literally would
say when someone says something negative
respond to that specifically and said
this product is oily I found it to be
not oily right like literally and so I
don't think that's step one in thinking
positive for a brand like I do think
that step one is buying collars yeah and
then I do think you can buy likes and
then I think you can like somehow buy
comments I saw some whole thing on it
yeah you can so something to talk about
yeah um it's just [ __ ] crazy I'm
proud to say I've never used send it
Riley I've not heard of it I if the name
looks familiar
I don't think I've ever heard of it but
you guys like come on what is this point
are you just losing like you're just you
I watched like on Shark Tank like it's
so hard to make money as a business to
begin with and then you're gonna spend
your profits I'm like just faking
success of your brand like maybe a
branch just not it like I don't know
call it quits
take a trip like who knows Thank You
true and you know what's so shocking
about this whole thing is that Sephora
sells this brand isn't Sephora supposed
to be like the you know the elitist
purveyor right yet even they don't know
that this Judis crap some people were
saying in the comments that they
actually really like Sunday Riley so
they don't know why they would have to
do this and I don't understand either
that makes it even I understand if you
have a shitty brand that makes it even
weirder but if it's good stuff like why
not just let the chips fall bring it and
let like your consumers have an honest
discussion like what a bunch of garbage
yeah it's really honestly with loose
areas [ __ ] yeah and this is embarrassing
for Sunday herself and I would like to
it's it's looser crime for sure yeah
this is just like I don't really care
cuz like this is just losers being
losers and like it's apparently
newsworthy but it's just I love when
people someone gets caught in corruption
you know it's interesting yeah like I do
hope when there's an American green
episode about this and I also would like
to see a show called loser court we're
like loser e crimes are prosecuted right
because it's like not really worth like
an actual courts time but if it's like
under than that like the premise of it
being like loser you crime like that
could be make for an interesting TV show
yeah like these are people who are
losers we get Caroline Callaway and
Natalie of course ode 1 episode 1 season
1 episode my pilot that's what'll sell
it yes
one episode to Sunday Riley versus the
people three nexium next yeah oh yeah
yeah that that actually might be a
two-part you know I did watch a nexium e
true Hollywood story did you bring my
call on losery crime and I mean I
couldn't watch without you in the back
of my head like loser who this is I'm
sorry
it was looser II and like I agreed with
you when you said it and now just
watching it it's like what were they
doing in Albany right no it's like
wasn't sexy at all I mean we're like he
was trying to make it seem like this
branded sex like and it's like it wasn't
even cool they were living in Albany
like it was yes and we were also talking
about before the show how these new e
true Hollywood stories they're not like
about people they're about like C ceases
like each one is like a question like
sex calls ourself held like Kim
Kardashian provocateur genius or later
called genius hip-hop does it
discriminate against women and like
that's the story is like the question
right no it's not it's not a biography
anymore no they're exploring a thesis or
hypothesis and it's curious I'm curious
I'm into it it's right for now we'll say
but what's the next episode uh the
hip-hop one came out in this up on
Sunday and then the next one and they
also don't tell you what then they play
these commercials with all these
different questions and people and I'm
like so who's being profiled that's what
I'm saying who's being profile you guys
like I really wanted to get behind true
Hollywood story and like I haven't
recorded on my TV but I just need you
guys to be a little more clear I'm like
what we're profiling on the scheduling
yes scheduling topics who it is like you
guys go back and forth and every episode
it's just in every uh sorry commercial
and I just need a little more clarity be
confusing
okay so glad you agree yeah okay it the
final story a little more is news
because it's a twofer oh but wait we
didn't report on the story that me and
my girl asked you to oh sorry in wedding
is Jennifer Lawrence lip got married
Luke Gallagher Jeremy Allen white got
married to his baby mama and longchamp
girlfriend Addison Tim Lee and like
honestly I'm really excited about it's
like I'm not gonna lie it should have
been me but if it wasn't like I guess it
should be the mother of his child you
know and they're like super cute and
low-key but like
interesting part about this whole thing
so the relative married is Addison Tim
Lee she's like an actress she's not like
super well-known but you know her face
you might know her face but she also has
like a lot of famous friends like she's
I think she's good friends too Sarah
Hyland and they got married at the
courthouse like literally them into
friends and like do you know who their
witness was Dakota Johnson Wow so just
like all so interesting you know I can
see her saying I can see her witnessing
yeah she I think she's best friends with
Addison so it's like Addison's like a
very well-known actress like amongst
actresses but not amongst the people you
know yeah interesting
yeah and he's just looking more handsome
than ever these days but that chiseled
jaw and that buzz cut and I just can't
he's so hot she looks like no you
honestly you might not think he's hot if
you don't watch the show because I would
say maybe like you know from a
third-party perspective just like you
know you see his face
not like conventionally handsome but
like his character super handsome and
like he's just really like an
interesting looking guy yeah that's
always what happens yeah so in a little
more wedding news Dennis Quaid got
engaged oh yes I heard to a 25 year old
who it's a tiara is a TA at the UT
Austin and is actually the teaching
assistant for many adjustor yeah they're
long history normal girls there's a lot
of toasters in the class
yeah I'm really here for it she's
beautiful she's beautiful Ted his place
seems like a good guy yeah I'm much of
inside if he was out a couple times
looking like a little you know wonky but
he doesn't seem like a bad guy yeah like
a dogs purpose you know yeah he's great
taste in films he is Creed emissary
facing film and women apparently yeah
cuz it's girls beauty but back to lip um
I just like do you think they have a lot
of money um I think that over the years
in shameless he definitely he definitely
remember they had that like riot they
wanted more money so but no but that was
just for Fiona
because she wasn't making as much money
as William H may see in honestly she was
right because she was the star of the
show and he was making more money than
her okay well anyway I feel like after
nine seasons off of a hit HBO show
Showtime Showtime
you're definitely making some good money
and I feel like he's an actor who can
really act on anything yeah but I've
seen crazy though like I agree with you
like if you're on a hit show like on
Showtime like you're gonna make a lot of
money like the affair but it's such an
ensemble cast there's like 10 main stars
look at your Thrones but they are making
money yeah
like that was a vision of the world that
I couldn't even deny but like I just I
really wanted him where there's like a
50 main characters yeah but still like
there's no way if you are Game of
Thrones you are making Bank like and you
made it till the end
well look at modern family there's a lot
of them in their upstream dig that's
very true so I don't think it should
affect yeah a lot of them but they're
fine
Julie's making a million dollars in
episode I'm sure honestly we can look it
up probably not a million because that's
usually like news and you guys but a
participant right well speaking of new
shows that proposed a show that we
should all watch and this isn't your
it's coming out of left field you
probably haven't even heard of it yet
Kristine broseph is starring in a new
show on Hulu that is based off a book
that everyone has been obsessed with I
didn't read it but I've literally never
seen fourth set over here she's from the
society she plays like the girl that
everyone wants to [ __ ] and and she's
also from Sierra Burgess the girl who
ended up being again and everyone wants
to find but I so I saw all the billboard
her news show Looking for Alaska
apparently like everyone it's like
it's amazing and it might be like a new
thing so I think let's get ahead of the
it and watch it okay so in 2017 it was
saying that well MH may see an emmy
rossum we're making 350 so lip is what
an episode yeah crazy I know it's four
episodes a month actually there's a lot
of episodes yeah they sent twenty
episodes see no write shorter like 15 15
episodes so that's for the char so lip
is now he's slowly becoming one the star
isn't a star news media in 2019 yeah I
think that's fair and how many episodes
15 okay that's over a million he's fine
yeah no I just think I'm just curious
yeah I said starting a white you know
he's starting a family as a child a wife
like she wouldn't know like are they
bringing home the bacon first sure a
couple mil a year and you know what it
you know what it really is it's like in
the show they play these this family
that's so for taxes they play this
family that's so poor like they don't
have a pot to piss in like your and
they're electric so he's getting cut off
so that's just kind of like what I
associate him with him I he just had a
child where's the challenge of them lay
up for you know yeah yeah I'm really
happy that I'm there like a cute little
family yeah that's cute I'm happy for
you guys that you're happy for that well
we're not like so happy because like I
think both of us wish that like it could
have been awesome and yeah but whatever
okay now this next 15 final story is a
twofer biz news because shoe guru
Shirou
Maddon wants to buy Barney's so oh my
god I am so glad that you brought this
up because I was thinking yesterday I
gotta tell Jackie to talk about bar save
the hashtag say Barney's okay see the
campaign I saw that just hashtag say
part you see the video yeah no Barney's
is closing out of business goodbye
goodbye goodbye it's a place after Real
Housewives it's a Bravo oh come on we
were saying it the whole time in LA and
then there's a boy at the end yes who'd
buy Barney's and I have to be honest I
don't know why I like this news it
doesn't like make me happy because like
it's like sad for the people who are
gonna lose their jobs but like Barney's
ain't it and they thought they were it
for so long and they have is just like
you go in there and everyone is an
[ __ ] no one helps you and there's
also nothing to actually wear or buy
it's all like blah no but what's the
word where it's like god guard clothing
it's like who the [ __ ] where the [ __ ] I
mean when everything this it's all
golden goose sneakers pre-warned ruined
sneakers and like I'm just so glad that
this is society saying that's not what
we want
no I couldn't agree more and this whole
campaign of being like hashtag say
Barney's it's like it's like Barney
shouldn't die reet it like it's like the
whole the slogan is like retail isn't
dead but it saved Barney's and it's like
okay I actually I'm here for the
argument like retailers shouldn't be
dead like mom-and-pop stores closing is
super sad and like I I
you should support local businesses and
I try to all the time but Barney's ain't
[ __ ] it and I have proof I have proof
that bottoms a [ __ ] ass of your kids
because I got a gift card from someone
$1,000 gift card at Barney's I've had it
in my wallet for three years I go in
there a couple times literally can't
find anything to buy and like first of
all nothing's $1000 it's like 1,700 I'm
like okay I don't even like it enough
I'm not going to spend more money I
spent 700 I can't buy Laurie cannot buy
something to lose this $1000 I'm like it
is in a worse store it's they they claim
to be like the most high end like it's a
staple of New York
they don't sell Chanel they don't sell
the way the time they don't sell Gucci
they literally on sale do you're like
they don't sell anything
it's [ __ ] trash all I just associate
them with Balenciaga and Balenciaga has
store Madison Avenue like I there's
nothing out there all these influencers
posting hashtag save Barneys why why why
are they special they didn't make it
they didn't evolve like there are tons
of stores Bergdorf Goodman is never been
more successful okay there's tons of
lucky stores that are doing a great job
and I said why should we say Barneys
we obviously didn't wanted enough Sookie
but um Wow hey
totally like and the people are hashtag
to say Barney's like do you go and shop
there like biting you support them
enough to keep them afloat no no I just
I don't like this campaign we should
save it because it's been around for a
while like it's a consumer like I have
money that I work hard on and I don't
want to [ __ ] spend and by the way if
we didn't save been Dells we're
definitely not gonna save Barney Jackie
like Bengals that was the travesty but
you know what once that lets it just
open the floodgates for everyone else to
go and you all laughed when it was been
Dallas how much her parties was like
yeah you it's [ __ ] like I just I'm
hating this entitlement that like
because Barney sells expensive things
like they deserve to stay around was
where is everyone
you know crying when they're closing on
the forever 21 well why is Barney so
special no it's the worst [ __ ] store
it's not and like they they have
everything they have the restaurant they
have the Madison Avenue they have
location they have they had the most
beautiful store but like they didn't
have it someone said caught it and you
didn't finish the gift card story that's
it I've never spent it and that's why I
got a business I really gotta go
I was gonna say yeah you have like xiana
bag you can get that big jacket maybe
Haga bag is silver house now yeah what
about that big jacket I keep getting ads
heard on Facebook as Balenciaga written
all over it it's like a big puffer it's
actually cute except like I don't like I
don't want to wear so much blends yada
there should be a website where you can
post your gift card there doesn't fit
the money in return yeah that's from the
other woman
gifts which or whatever that her idea oh
you're right doesn't exist because I
don't really I mean I'm now I'm sure I
couldn't get anything for it because the
source [ __ ] oh yeah but no it
definitely exists okay I really want to
get rid of this gift card cuz I could
really use a thousand dollars no you
wouldn't get $1,000 for it's not equal
because it's you're not you would get a
little bit she's not a joke yeah but
then it's just
it's not but anyways shoe guru Steve
Madden was putting together an
eleventh-hour bid to buy Barneys New
York's so interested source is
exclusively told page six but like Steve
Madden you're going on business
everywhere you try to go to Steve Madden
in New York you finally find the
location you show up there and away I
went up to [ __ ] 86th Street to go to
though one Steve Madden left no no there
used to be so many and now every time I
walk to wise oh it's close so I go find
like the next one for the next time I go
by the time I get there it's closed so
usually one for two nights closes in as
in not like off hours as a business and
you know what's so funny like this is
cute Steve Madden but like you've gotten
like 1,000 cease and desist notice for
your website to take down shoes that are
copyrights of items that are sold at
Barney's and like I would think they
would let you buy Barney's you know I
mean it's not about letting but I just
don't know we're getting this money and
if you have so much money like can we
get some stores so I really need to see
mad and back in cylinder if you thought
it is one of the best shoe stores like
it completely agree it's and you know
online it's just sounds the same like I
really need to see the shoes in high
school like I went to see Madden all the
time there was one right by where we
lived it doesn't exist anymore now the
way it moved to 86th Street I went there
a couple times it wasn't as good it was
much smaller but still went out of
business like I think there's still one
on 34th Street and Herald Square is is
Barney still like operating today I
think she go yeah someone said we should
do a patreon of you trying to spend the
gift card oh that's a good idea
let's go today before you never know
when it's gonna click let me get through
this [ __ ] article bids were due in
the Barney's bankruptcy bonanza on
Tuesday it's unclear who Madden was
partnering with in the bid but a source
full page six Eve's from New York of
course he's obsessed with Barney's he's
obsessed with the brand I'm obsessed
with the location like yes I really hope
I mean it would be tragic if that just
becomes like office space but no Madison
Avenue miss premium like I hope we got a
ton of premium things I'm gonna [ __ ]
indoor ice skating rink okay I hope we
get a revolve store yes like a brand
that can really keep up with the times
yeah it's a city block and it's like
eight flight eight stories high that
could be something really good I know
Barney's is literally sitting there
wasting away honestly it's sad it's
probably gonna just be like an Apple
store that's what I was because there is
an Apple store on Madison like ten
blocks up so maybe it'll be like what
company has enough money
do that right my kannaway luggage
shortly we work except like there just
went on business no they're on they're
teetering on the edge but if they
weren't in that precarious situation it
would be a we were yeah what a beautiful
space where we were yeah honestly like
we would have to move there and get a
studio a hundred percent yeah
interesante maybe it'll be at McDonald's
try that it would be amazing oh maybe
just like a mall and but that's like so
pedestrian but like Madison Avenue so
snotty but like a mall would be lit or
they'll just like break it up sell off
the floors right apartment oh my god
Manship some about that is her house oh
my god I think they made it started as a
house yes you know I actually wrote a
paper on Bergdorf's it's actually a very
thin argument I made and I really
couldn't you know write a lot about it
but on the top floor you speed up an
apartment for Bergdorf and Goodman yeah
very nice yeah but now it's a salon
that's a great documentary everyone
should watch it better my ashes at
Bergdorf's very informative and really
makes you think of the retail the retail
landscape yeah and they'll definitely
like make you love Bergdorf's and not
like Barneys and you know was most
interesting part of that um documentary
was that they did a whole part of the
series on the the top personal stylists
there and they said based on commissions
like some of their best you know sales
people are making 500 grand a year so
crazy that's cool yeah Maddon has been
in acquisition mode in August his brand
who snapped up sneaker brand greats and
women's line BB Dakota like that I just
wore maybe Dakota BB Dakota he just he
actually just wore BB Dakota in LA Thank
You Brent yes he also owns lines
including Betsey Johnson Brian Atwood
and Blondo the company reported second
quarter revenues the four hundred and
forty five million dollars this year we
that's so crazy I don't know that I knew
them but he had brought Betsey Johnson
Betsey Johnson craft he like I guess
like likes to buy things Irene Crabb
like Betsey Johnson he's a businessman
yeah good for him it's pretty cool it's
pretty cool now that you said it like
there's no doubt in my mind that
Barney's gonna be bought by like a big
real estate man and it's gonna become
apartments like with storefront no but
it's just gonna be broken up it won't be
sick it'll just be like any other block
on Madison Avenue that's sad because
like the building is wonderful that is
heaven like this will only turn into a
sad story if whatever they do with that
real estate since it's like so stark
it's so beautiful and in such a great
area if what they do with it is bad then
this becomes a sad story but I can't
stress enough how not sad it is that
Barney's is going out of buzzing I just
I I hate that they're latching onto like
this whole retail is dying like no
offense Barney's didn't die because
retail is dying like there are plenty of
expensive stores that a managed to stay
in business
Barney's is dying because they have
terrible clothing yeah terrible clothing
terrible item no one's there to help
everyone is so judgmental there had been
so many stories about people going into
Barney's and like being refused service
and like they were discriminatory and
they just had a [ __ ] stick up their
ass and it's time time's up no and if
ever like any of these influencers who
are being approached to post this hash
I'd say Barney's video like I have no
respect for you like I can't stress that
enough no totally totally totally ok
Jeff Jeff sorry David sighs Oh Jensen
with the Stars yes so she begins with
the Jeffrey starts I only turned it on
at 9:45 because we got home from the
airport and I was gonna restart it cuz I
wanted to watch Lauren Elena but
homegirl went last I watched Lauren
Alaina and then I watched everyone go
home and it was so premium like that's
how you gotta watch dance with the Stars
and we also went to dance with the Stars
and I watch it through a different lens
every time people are being told to clap
every time I heard clapping I was
literally triggered it was of the clap
so who ends up on y'all celebrate
because celebrate she could not stop
crying it was so crazy like I get that
it's like a heightened emotions and I'm
sure like now she's finally she doesn't
really care but like in the moment it's
like very much like an incubator of
feelings but she really needs to calm
down like she knows like you don't mind
embarrassing like all the people like
they cut 2 credits like all the pros
were around her like look at each other
be like why she cry so much like know
like exactly it was like it was it was
so much pressure she was dancing in the
name of her mom and I know but so that's
why it's like it doesn't even matter how
good or bad she did like her just doing
it was like really admirable and I think
even the fact that you made it this far
like I was really proud like her time
was up yeah I thought she in reality
like who was voting for her event she
doesn't have like a huge fan base like
she has nobody to rely on except her
mother's fans and it just like it mates
know how active like the Bruce Lee
cooker sorry right so like a mate sends
a news dad I was shocked that Ally
Brooke was in the bottom two I was
shocked like where the Harmonizers but
then the end Margo really got the scores
couldn't those keep her out
nation judges scores and voting she had
top scores last me right but which means
she must have absolutely no votes right
so me and Margaret were like doing an
investigation to where the Harmonizers
like they were so powerful for so long
but I guess our fifth harmony has really
been disbanded for like so long like
literally nobody cares
the Harmonizers have broken up yeah and
it was shocking yeah I don't know I
thought she would really have like a
strong fan base to be you know calling
in from all their parents phones ten
times you know yeah but no Wow crazy Wow
tides turn for everyone but lordling
dance to her new song called the other
side which is learned Athena dancer
heart ruling the damage to the other
side song is incredible oh my god it's
so good and she had played it for me
like two weeks ago and told me that it's
like about her stepdad yeah I am I have
it inside scoop and basically like he
was sick for a long time and then the
day he passed away like like hours
before he passed away like he was like
in heaven and then he was like
describing to them like he saw Jesus he
saw his mom like that's what the whole
song is about like I've been feeling the
songs gonna become like the pop
Christian anthem of our generation oh
wow I've been listening to it and I
didn't even realize it was about that
cuz you like apply it all to yourself
and so I just thought is that a
situation where it's like I'll see you
on the other side where it's like you'll
get through this and I look forward to
seeing you like on the other side of
this situation that's just cool that you
can like interpret it definitely but no
it's like based off and then she danced
because it was the one-year anniversary
of her stepdad passing away who she was
like really really close to in her other
song um getting good when she's talking
about like being on the phone with her
dad like so it's a different dad it's
her it's my biological dad um and this
song is about her stepdad okay that's
missing God now because that makes the
song even sad that part of the song is
so sad like I'm afraid of both my
parents dying like oh my god
triggered triggered your music it's just
like absolutely slapping like from a
country base from perspective from a
Christian perspective and just I'm like
an all-around someone who appreciates
good music you know with end like song
writing the lyrics in the spirit like I
just can't come there is so much spirit
in lyrics so much so check it out now
let's talk about Jeffrey star we have
recently fallen in love with the series
Shane Dawson is putting on the fabulous
life a secret life the dangerous world
of jeffree star I actually went back and
watched the first series that really and
it's so funny because when they start
this
series Jeffrey says Dechaine is like you
have no idea how much you changed my
life
yes and then I wanted to know why so I
went back and watched the first series
and it's not as good as the second
series I think the second ones actually
a lot better but um I guess when they
released that that documentary like
Jeffrey was still very much like
controversial from his cancellation but
he talked a lot about it I think people
got to see like he's just a person and I
think that like blew up his business and
his channel and his whole brand even
more so now watching them I think what
they're doing is so interesting like how
they're paralleling like them of
creating this brand with them like now
leading up to launch and like when the
last episode drops the palettes gonna
draw yeah and like all the products well
it's supposed to be nine episodes we've
gotten four and it drops on November
first who are we getting um five more
episodes in the next week is this a
month of patreon that would be really
fun I would die yeah I'm like really
enjoying it and now I keep checking it
my day now he's made to work I'm like so
invested in honestly at first I was like
what is she I'm so happy I thought you
were gonna hate it like the first
episode was really hard to get through
when it was all about his anxiety about
flying and it's like I don't care like
no I like the Chad stop you're on a
private jet like we all don't like
flying like we don't just don't talk
about it like don't talk about like the
plane going down it's like I'm he was
putting in footage of like private
planes going down it's like we like we
all have a fear that our plane is gonna
go down like yeah deal with it I don't
know by the way did you freak out when
the day he was supposed to get engaged
he got like a whole canceled thing ie I
did that was crazy because that's
literally what happened to you it's
literally what happened to me and it's
like life waits it for no one no it
really doesn't but didn't okay and you
didn't watch the first series but
there's one part where they wanted to
like make Shane look like Geoffrey so
they brought in James Charles to do his
makeup so Shane Geoffrey and James are
all sitting there and they were calling
themselves the controversy Queens
because like they've all gone through
and something about it like I just was
like living for like how much light they
were making of like their own like
situations and I was like a really like
put into perspective for me I'm like no
we're like everyone goes through this
[ __ ] like Oh totally and like we and so
as much as like I do enjoy talking about
it because I think it's interesting like
we also just need to move the [ __ ] on
like yeah and the way that Jeffery talks
about him like I'm sure in that episode
he talked about like the controversy but
now he's just like people want to bring
you down like and you like it's just
really empower
yeah so true yeah and they and literally
like they're gonna sell half a million
pallets they have 20 million viewers per
episode but you only and he said he was
like the silent majority like when
people love you like they just enjoy
when people don't like you then they
have something to say and it's like hate
like is the only emotion that speaks so
loud you know and speaks the loudest so
it's like it's very it can like drown
out those like select people cuz that's
not like everyone else is just quietly
enjoying watching you your and
supporting you yes so it is so
interesting and really and they are like
they are like awesome I'm like such a
bigger scale right and so even Shane and
like the cat it's like he like couldn't
look at his cat my name is hilarious it
was hilarious like that is so crazy and
so stupid I'm sure he said something
stupid but like he doesn't [ __ ] his cat
like yeah anyways the first episode I
almost gave up because I was like the
plane and like I was just like are you
[ __ ] kidding me where's Geoffrey yeah
right Shane is not the star of the
series at all no but like in the
beginning he's getting more spare time
Geoffrey and it was annoying to me and
then like I was just like sticking
around for the glimpses of Geoffrey and
now we're in the thick of it and I join
it and at first I was like why would
anyone buy like Shane's palette like I
didn't get it either he's like who
doesn't do makeup he doesn't do makeup I
wouldn't take like makeup advice from
him necessarily and now he's getting
into makeup so that he can be an expert
on the subject which is good for him but
it's not even about him knowing how did
you make up it's about using his brand
something that like he's been building
for so long that he's never really he
monetized
or whether they did cash grab what they
say and using that as a theme for a
palette which is just cool and then
you're buying Geoffrey
well yeah it's like you're buying
Geoffrey you know that it's good quality
good packaging like it's the best of the
best but then it's like you're
supporting an influencer like it's
actually so crazy when he talks about
how like he was the first person on
YouTube and like all these people have
surpassed him all these people and like
he like joke says he's like the poor
friend and like by no means a seaport he
is like a very nice house that he's a
golf cart and I drives around on but
it's like seeing all these kids like
pass him by and it sucks because his
motive has never been money as what if
it should always just been to make
content and and he makes money from that
meaning he like can live his life and
like that be his job but it like sucks
yeah to see everyone like pass you by
yeah the financials are unbelievably and
your most interesting but also I think
the most interesting part is two things
one I always just
- no like how jeffrey makes so much
money and I know that his cosmetics is
super successful but I don't even think
that's like its number one well it's the
fact that he merged companies and also
owns his cosmetics he's not like
partnering with anyone he's making every
does have a business partner he said no
but like he doesn't um it's not like
when people do collabs with makeup
companies and like Nicky to toe that was
crazy
what's tutorial it's the tutorials
making fifty grand with toothpaste right
he's has the skin in the game and then
he also owns the operations and then can
also license it out to other people like
all those buildings like could you yeah
right but then I thought the most
interesting part is that also this
series is now power paralleling the the
James Charles trauma so you see in the
beginning when in being like James is
doing so good we're so proud of him he's
like my little brother I love like all
these boxes is all of his merch and by
the way this merch that I have his
killer merch this was before the whole
thing but now James isn't with killer
merch know so I think it unravels on the
show okay and also what's interesting
and I was reading an article and is
proof that [ __ ] these youtubers are
so interesting they need a reality show
and like I know this is basically a
reality show but like this would be
[ __ ] interesting yeah but it's but
it's like it happened so fast and in
this instance it is interesting to watch
back but it's like when something
happened six months ago and then we see
it six months later it's like YouTube is
the reality
yeah that's term that also Oh what was
interesting is the James Charles Morphy
collaboration palette came out on
November 1st last year and they actually
moved like you you heard more if you say
like we might have an issue because we
have James this anniversary palette this
might've been on the episode that I
missed oh they had a call with morphe it
was a small thing over over they had the
call with more if you didn't you see
that no oh okay well then that's what
you missed but anyways they like they
asked you have anyone else like coming
out around that time any other clubs and
they were like well we have James's
anniversary of his morphe collaboration
which should have been on November first
but it actually came out two weeks ago
yes so we think yeah for this yeah I
just thought it just came out but it's
it's it's you name palette but it's a
mini but that's just what they did to
yellow like this big collection so but
they didn't even end up doing the morphe
exclusive though what are they doing
it's worldwide everywhere Geoffrey was
tweeting all about it they decided about
to do an exclusive because he wanted it
to be everywhere oh [ __ ] yeah
it's at I wonder if I start its they
sell it at morphe stores and all
retailers where jeffree star cosmetics
is sold mostly international I look
forward to seeing where how they come to
this decision because Geoffrey seemed
like this was the best decision yeah
maybe it's like exclusive to morphe in
the US and then internationally
everywhere no Geoffrey said they're
blowing it up and they decided not to go
DISA lose it like he literally did that
verbatim you guys may be confused
because they announced recently like a
few days ago that the pallets coming out
on November 1st available everywhere
Geoffrey cosmetics Tarte cosmetics is
sold and then he was a lot of you guys
might be confused after seeing this
week's episode about the exclusive but
we just wanted to blow it up and have it
be everywhere so maybe something felt
there with the morphe collab maybe but
cool I mean the people that work for
Jeffrey aside from the ones that steal
from him are like really smart in really
town guy who's in head of like I think
as Mohawk know like the big guy yeah
yeah like it's just so it's so funny and
how like the people they're not there
see like they do not want to be on
camera they're very like straight they
got those [ __ ] things that you like
press into the eyeshadow like the yeah
so they got those made in a second and
they were also good like I just thought
it was so he has a real like [ __ ]
operation yeah and his office is a cute
it's not glamorous it's not like the
best best like Kylie it's just you get
[ __ ] work done there yeah and there's
cubicles and I'm also really like
interested to see their houses like and
their furniture and stuff and it's
actually making me like sad because my
house like still isn't done I'm like
Shane Dawson's house is done and like
you doesn't even care about these things
yeah I can't if I can are in Jeremy's
but yank it right totally and he I have
an army sling that I never touch except
like if this is art and he just like
wraps himself up in it then I actually
like used it to take it back what's the
cup to Rome it was nice yeah um just the
whole thing is so interesting and like
I'm really now I'm like really obsessed
with knowing more about Geoffrey like he
said his his businesses are in obviously
cosmetics the merch like the warehouses
that he owns real estate and cannabis so
I just want to know like what's the
biggest earner and I think human Nate
are so cute and I can just like help
he's just very open like he's like yeah
I mean they are like we love each other
but we suck other people like he's just
like very um and doesn't say that maybe
in the old series
didn't live for having threesomes and
like there it's like sex it's like a
fluid thing no I am gonna watch old
series yeah it's not as good and
glamorous it's like then it's like they
watch the first one I knew what people
really liked and they put all of that
into the second one but there's just
something really he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] like about anyone or anything I'm
like that's cool
yeah but then he also is like self-aware
and like worried about set like he's not
just like living in another land in a
parable he thinks that his [ __ ] doesn't
stink yet he's always worried about like
things flopping and it's just he's a
relatable Queen yeah okay
snatcher sent me some news well that
authentic brands offers to purchase
Barney's out of bankruptcy for two
hundred and seventy 1 million dollars
which I actually think means that
Barney's will I continue a licensing
company that owns our pastel and Juicy
Couture has put in a two hundred and
seventy 1 million dollar bid to purchase
luxury brand Barneys out of bankruptcy
with a plan to place the stores inside
Saks Fifth Avenue stories we intercept
so they're still gonna close that main
one
I don't maybe they can't afford the rent
anymore twice on Sony mill is way too
much I'm sorry they're flopping yeah I'm
sure they they take a hundred mil but
other people are putting together bids
to like Ben Avraham the co-founder of
kiss Oh kiss and Barney's makes a lot of
sexually I can't has enough money but
they're they're working with other
investors to get more match so it seems
as a party's not going but 271 mils to
buy Barney's like I would have thought
it would be more I thought oh I thought
I'd be less but I guess you don't get
that uh that land you're just buying a
brand that you guys worthless right now
this is so crazy to me like you guys
name
this stupid brand is going out of
business like really no one will be
affected like it'll be sad for people
who care about like fashion but for the
most part like the world will be fine
but suddenly you know all these people
have two hundred and seventy million
dollars just give away like there's not
enough people coming she's mad and
authentic brands give and it's like you
know there hasn't been water in Michigan
for like thirty years and these people
are silent like it's just so funny like
when people come forward with their
money it's not they're coming forward to
donate it
it's like suddenly all these people have
money you know these people have always
had money it's just funny cuz it's like
this brand is obviously terrible like
the buying it to save Barney's like the
influencers are asking you to they're
buying it as a business like Barney like
as an investment even though we
personally don't chop it like Chinese is
a brochure international I just save
money I just think it is funny it's not
to say like that yeah cuz you're funny
I'm well I think that's all she wrote
today but my armpits are so sweaty I
think it's time to go I think it's time
to go as a reminder our merch store is
open things are still in stock as we
promised that they would be so head over
to shop morning toast calm to thank you
for being patient get whatever you want
enjoy and just wrap morning toast like
like this natural also our new tienen
show with Lauren Elizabeth called mood
with Lauren Elizabeth launches tomorrow
it's now available on Spotify and iTunes
so feel free check it out search mood
with Lauren Elizabeth or just Lauren
Elizabeth it will come up on subscribe
leave a review support our girl tomorrow
and we do have a new tienen show
dropping pretty soon after Lauren so
exciting stuff stay tuned dot merch
stores open shop morning shows calm I
launched six new shows for the dirty
jeans tour at Verona New York JT Verona
Tarrytown New York Ontario Ontario
Kansas City Missouri in the city um
Margo Turning Stone
that's the stones yeah what were the
other ones Oh Englewood New Jersey
Bergen County and one more check them
out girls no job comm they're selling
really well so thank you guys for that
also got your tickets before they're
gone if you weren't able to get the
tickets to the show with the beacon
which I know a lot of you weren't there
are now areas like Englewood Verona
Tarrytown around that you can get
tickets too and it'll be really fun I'm
really excited it's gonna be a wonderful
follow me I'd takeo problems because my
content is so [ __ ] premium right now I
don't know if I should ever post on
Instagram again because that's the tough
thing about I he flow is since L a blow
on Filipe my flow is on fleek and I just
I don't know my first picture back is
just gonna be like a gray cloud I just
sounded like such a grandma a lovely
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast Emiliano millennium
morning show where we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube feel free to subscribe at the
morning toast YouTube leave a review you
know how you do not only were you in the
comment also available as a podcast
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio IR
radio anywhere you can listen to
podcasts so feel free to search
subscribe morning toast leave a review
dude you do maybe a week should they
leave a review when that's were sighs
yeah okay but we don't want to be
something right but in no means am I you
know paying for views bribe interviews
just like if you're feeling organically
and if you're watching the show and
you've made it to this point like I
assume you enjoyed it leave a review
about how you've enjoyed it it may need
longtime joint it it means a lot to us
but in no means are we you know
endorsing a review we're just your
singer of you but we're not purchasing
know we're not people trying to get
anything from us no anyways that's all
she wrote now see you tomorrow
you